>> Jon: WE'RE BACK.
WELCOME TO "THE DAILY SHOW."
SO NICE TO SEE YOU.
MY NAME IS JON STEWART.
MY GUEST TONIGHT DAVID ROSE
AUTHOR OF "ENCHANTED OBJECTS."
OBVIOUSLY, THOUGH, THE EMMYS.
COLBERT REPORT. CONGRATULATIONS,
TO THEM. ALWAYS WELL DESERVED.
ONCE AGAIN. GREAT JOB. BUT
FIRST, OBVIOUSLY, THE BIG NEWS
OF THE LAST FEW WEEKS, THE TOWN
OF FERGUSON, MISSOURI.
WHERE THE SHOOTING BY POLICE OF
TEENAGER MICHAEL BROWN HAS
SPARKED A SERIES OF PROTESTS,
WHICH IN TURN SPARKED A LET'S
SAY STERN RESPONSE BY POLICE
WHO APPEAR TO BE
AUDITIONING FOR
ROBO COP. IT'S A, IT'S A STORY
THAT HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUTRAGED AND UPSET.
>> I CAME BACK FROM VACATION
BECAUSE I'M FURIOUS.
>> OF COURSE YOU ARE. AN UNARMED
BLACK TEENAGER GUNNED DOWN
IN THE STREETS BY POLICE UNDER
SUSPICIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHO WOULDN'T CUT THEIR VACATION
SHORT TO REGISTER THEIR FURY.
YOU'D HAVE TO BE A MONSTER OR IN
MY CASE ENJOYING A PARTICULARLY
NICE VACATION.
BUT GOOD ON YOU, MR. O'REILLY,
FOR COMING BACK.
UNLESS OF COURSE YOU'RE FURIOUS
ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
>> FURIOUS ABOUT HOW THE
SHOOTING DEATH OF 18-YEAR-OLD
MICHAEL BROWN IS BEING
REPORTED, AND HOW VARIOUS
PEOPLE ARE REACTING TO IT.
>> Jon: YES!
THAT IS THE OUTRAGE.
THE SHOOTING OF MICHAEL BROWN
AND ANY LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
FROM THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR SAID INCIDENT IS
OUTRAGEOUS IN HOW IT HAS BEEN
REPORTED.
[LAUGHING]
>> AND, I GUESS THAT'S NOT THE
ONLY REASON TO BE ANGRY.
>> IS HE GOING TO GET A FARE
SHAKE, THIS OFFICER?
>> THERE HAS BEEN A RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
>> ERIC HOLDER FLIES INTO
FERGUSON.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW, WITH HIS, WITH HIS,
YOU KNOW, SUPER HERO CAPE.
>> THIS MANTRA OF THE UNARMED
BLACK TEENAGER SHOT BY A WHITE
COP. YOU KNOW, THAT DESCRIPTION
IN AND OF ITSELF ACTUALLY COLORS
THE WAY
IN WHICH WE LOOK AT THIS STORY.
>> Jon: YES, DESCRIBING THE
ACTUAL FACTS OF THE CASE.
[LAUGHING]
>> Jon: REALLY DOES COLOR THE
WAY WE LOOK AT IT.
WHITE COP, SHOOTS UNARMED BLACK
TEEN.
DOES SOUND TERRIBLE.
WHERE AS SAY HERO COP KILLS
ALIEN HUNTING HUMANS FOR SPORT
WOULD PUT A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SPIN ON THINGS.
WHICH THOUGH A VERY ACCURATE
DESCRIPTION OF THE PLOT OF
PREDATOR TWO, IS IN THIS CASE
IS -- NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
AND, YOU KNOW WHAT THERE ARE SO
MANY OTHER STORIES OUT THERE.
>> WHY AREN'T WE COVERING NEW
YORK.
>> WHY AREN'T WE COVERING BLACK
ON BLACK CRIME.
>> Jon: YES! WHY ALL THE
INTEREST IN HOLDING POLICE
OFFICERS TO A HIGHER
STANDARD THAN GANGS?
THEY BOTH FLASH COLORS. AND,
YES ONE OF THEM HAS BEEN
SWORN TO PROTECT AND DEFEND, BUT
STILL --
>> WELL, THIS WEEKEND 42 PEOPLE
WERE SHOT IN CHICAGO.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T SEE THE
PROTESTS.
I DON'T SEE THE ANGER.
>> IF I WERE AFRICAN-AMERICAN I
WOULD BE OUTRAGED THAT MORE
JOURNALISTS AREN'T COVERING
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CHICAGO AND
MORE OUTRAGED THAT PEOPLE LIKE
AL SHARPTON AND JESSE JACKSON
DON'T HEAD TO THOSE AREAS.
>> Jon: YES. WHAT COULD EXPLAIN
THE LACK OF OUTRAGE ABOUT
AL SHARPTON AND HIS ILK NOT
DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT BLACK ON BLACK
VIOLENCE IN CHICAGO.
>> WITH CHICAGO'S VIOLENCE
MAKING NATIONAL HEADLINES, A
GROUP LED BY THE REVEREND AL
SHARPTON PLANS TO CONVENE AN
ANTI-VIOLENCE SUMMIT OF NATIONAL
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS HERE.
>> Jon: OH, THAT'S RIGHT BECAUSE
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERS DID
HOLD A SUMMIT ABOUT THAT IN
NOVEMBER. AND HAVE MET AT
LEAST THREE TIMES IN THE CITY
IN JUST THE LAST 13 MONTHS.
WHICH IS NOT TO SAY THAT IT'S
BEEN EFFECTIVE. BUT TAKEN ALONG
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S MY
BROTHER'S KEEPER INITIATIVE
WHICH ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THIS
VIOLENCE, ALONG WITH THE
COUNTLESS VIGILS AND MARCHES
WITHIN THESE VIOLENCE TORN
COMMUNITIES MEANS THEY ARE
TRYING ACTUALLY TO DO SOMETHING.
YOU SEE, YOU BEING IGNORANT OF
THOSE ATTEMPTS DOESN'T MEAN
THE ISSUE ITSELF IS BEING
IGNORED IN THE SAME WAY THAT
WHEN IT SNOWS WHERE
YOU LIVE DOESN'T MEAN THE WORLD
ISN'T GETTING HOTTER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: [BLEEP]. OH, YOU KNOW
WHAT? THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
BOTHERING YOU, ISN'T THERE?
>> WHEN A COP PULLS ME OVER I
SAY, I PUT MY HANDS OUTSIDE OF
THE CAR. IF I'M CARRYING A
WEAPON, WHICH I'M LICENSED TO
CARRY IN NEW YORK, THE FIRST
THING I TELL THE POLICE OFFICER
IS "OFFICER I WANT YOU TO KNOW I
HAVE A LEGAL FAREARM IN THE
CAR."
>> Jon: AND THEN I BRACE MYSELF
FOR THE TASER.
WELL, WITHOUT GETTING INTO THE
FACT YOU GET PULLED OVER SO MUCH
BY THE COPS THAT SOMETIMES
YOU'RE CARRYING A WEAPON.
SOMETIMES YOU'RE NOT. I DON'T
KNOW.
DEPENDS ON HOW I'M FEELING THAT
DAY.
BUT, CONTINUE.
>> I OFTEN WOULD EVEN TAKE MY --
STEP OUT OF THE CAR, LIFT MY
SHIRT UP SO HE COULD
SEE WHERE THE GUN IS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Jon: YOU REALLY DO HAVE NO
[BEEP] IDEA, DO YOU?
YOU REALLY DON'T. BASICALLY,
BASICALLY YOU'RE SAYING...
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
IF ONLY MICHAEL BROWN INSTEAD OF
HOLDING
HIS HANDS OVER HIS HEAD HAD
REACHED DOWN TO HIS WAIST ND
LIFTED UP HIS SHIRT TO SHOW THE
GUN HE DID NOT ACTUALLY HAVE,
WELL, THIS WHOLE TRAGEDY COULD
OF BEEN AVOIDED.
DO YOU NOT UNDERSTAND THAT LIFE
IN THIS COUNTRY IS INHERENTLY
DIFFERENT FOR WHITE PEOPLE AND
BLACK PEOPLE?
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE TRYING
MAKE THIS, DANA, ABOUT BLACK AND
WHITE. AND TRYING TO MAKE THIS
ABOUT RACE.
>> THIS IS PART OF THIS EFFORT
TO MAKE IT EVERYTHING ABOUT
RACE.
>> IS THIS A STORY ABOUT RACE?
DO WE KNOW THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S PLACING THE RACE
CARD.
AND I THINK IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
>> THE ONLY RACIAL DIVIDE THAT
IS BEING CREATED HERE IS
BEING CREATED BY
THE RACE HATERS.
>> YOU KNOW WHO TALKS ABOUT
RACE, RACISTS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Jon: DID YOU JUST -- HE WHO
SMELT IT DEALT IT RACISM.
DID YOU REALLY? YOU SMELT IT
DEALT IT RACISM?
ALRIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Jon: FORGET THAT IN
FERGUSON, 94% OF THE POLICE ARE
WHITE AND 63% OF THE PEOPLE ARE
BLACK, FORGET THAT 92% OF
POLICE SEARCHES AND 86% OF CAR
STOPS ARE FOR BLACK PEOPLE.
FORGET THAT THE WHITE MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCES NEARLY A
QUARTER OF ITS ANNUAL BUDGET
THROUGH THE FINES
DISPROPORTIONATELY LEVELED
AGAINST THE BLACK POPULATION.
FORGET THAT THE HISTORY OF THIS
TOWN INCLUDES THIS TASTY NUGGET.
>> A 52-YEAR-OLD MAN NAMED HENRY
DAVIS SAID THAT FOUR FERGUSON
POLICE OFFICERS BEAT HIM AND
THEN CHARGED HIM WITH DAMAGING
GOVERNMENT PROPERTY BECAUSE HIS
BLOOD HAD GOTTEN ON THE
OFFICERS' UNIFORMS.
>> Jon: SO, LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT. YOU GUYS
HAVE GOT TANKS BUT YOU CAN'T
KEEP A COUPLE OF TIDE STICKS
AROUND. BECAUSE HERE'S...
HERE IS THE PROBLEM WITH
EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING ON IN
THIS CONVERSATION.
THIS ISN'T ALL ABOUT JUS ONE
MAN KILLED IN ONE TOWN.
IT'S ABOUT HOW PEOPLE OF COLOR,
NO MATTER THEIR SOCIOECONOMIC
STANDING FACE OBSTACLES IN THIS
COUNTRY WITH SURPRISING GRACE.
LOOK AT, LOOK AT HOW UPSET YOU
ALL GET ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS.
>> TONIGHT CHRISTMAS UNDER
ATTACK.
>> Jon: WHY ARE WE ALLOWING
ANTI- CHRISTMAS MADNESS?
>> WHY DO I HAVE TO DRIVE AROUND
WITH MY KIDS TO LOOK FOR
NATIVITY SCENES AND BE LIKE,
OH YA, KIDS, LOOK THERE BABY
JESUS BEHIND THE FESTIVUS POLE
MADE OUT OF BEER CANS.
IT'S NUTS!
>> REMEMBER...
>> Jon: REMEMBER, YOU WERE
FURIOUS THAT AMERICA'S
11 MONTH LONG CELEBRATION OF
CHRISTMAS WASN'T ENOUGH. BUT
NOW IF YOU CAN, JUST IMAGINE
THAT INSTEAD OF HAVING TO SUFFER
THE INDIGNITY OF A FESTIVUS POLE
BLOCKING SOMETHING YOU COULD
HAVE JUST SET UP IN YOUR OWN
YARD ANYWAY -- IMAGINE THAT
INSTEAD OF THAT ON A PRETTY
CONSISTENT BASIS YOU CAN'T GET A
[BEEP] CAB EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE A NEURO SURGEON,
CAUSE YOU'RE BLACK.
I GUARANTEE YOU.
I GUARANTEE YOU THAT EVERY, I
GUARANTEE YOU THAT EVERY, THAT
EVERY PERSON OF COLOR IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS FACED AM INDIGNITY
FROM THE RIDICULOUS, TO THE
GROTESQUE, TO THE SOMETIMES
FATAL AT SOME POINT IN
THEIR -- I'M GONNA SAY
LAST COUPLE OF HOURS. BECAUSE OF
THEIR SKIN COLOR.
QUICK STORY.
SO WE LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY.
A LIBERAL BASTION.
RECENTLY -- LET ME FINISH.
RECENTLY WE SENT A CORRESPONDENT
AND A PRODUCER TO A BUILDING
IN THIS LIBERAL BASTION WHERE WE
WERE GOING TO TAPE AN INTERVIEW.
THE PRODUCER, WHITE, DRESSED IN
WHAT COULD ONLY BE DESCRIBED AS
HOMELESS ELF ATTIRE, AND A
PRETTY STRONG 5:00 O'CLOCK FROM
THE PREVIOUS WEEK SHADOW.
STRODE CONFIDENTIALLY INTO THE
BUILDING PROCEEDING OUR HUMBLE
CORRESPONDENT, A GENTLEMAN OF
COLOR, DRESSED RESPLENDENTLY IN
A TAILORED SUIT. WHO DO YOU
THINK WAS STOPPED?
LET ME GIVE YOU A HINT: THE
BLACK GUY.
AND THAT [BLEEP] HAPPENS ALL OF
THE TIME.
ALL OF IT.
RACE IS THERE.
AND IT IS A CONSTANT.
YOU'RE TIRED OF HEARING ABOUT
IT?
IMAGE HOW [BEEP] EXHAUSTING IT
IS LIVING IT.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.